hi everyone my name is William
this talk is kuda and your python so i'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
how we can start programming on the GPU
from the safety of our Python program in
the language we're familiar with so I
want to start off with some bad news
Moore's law is dead this is kind of a
tough one
so Moore's law what was it basically an
idea that the number of transistors that
you can fit on an integrated circuit
would double every two years initially
was every one year actually he had to
revise that and this is Gordon Moore
namesake of the law and so he based it
on this data so you can see this graph
on the left side it's a log scale so the
linear nature of it says that it's
doubling and you can see this help from
like the 50s 60s 70s this actually went
up all the way till the 2016 which this
is with some like actual data so you can
see that relationship pretty much holds
true I mean it's doubling and doubling
up until 2016 but honestly we're
starting to hit a plateau a lot of
people like to write about it there's a
lot of headlines popping up what are we
doing now Moore's law is dead and all
these things and you know you might ask
is is this really true and I'll say I
trust this guy this guy says I guess I
see Moore's law dying here in the next
decade or so but that's not surprising
I'm who is this guy this is Gordon Moore
he said that in 2015 so if he said it I
think we can start to buy into this idea
that at least over the next I mean he
said it in 2015 so over the next five
years we're gonna start to see a plateau
in you know getting more and more
transistors onto these chips and so this
leaves us the question why I'm up here
talking to about GPUs and and how can
they help us kind of combat this problem
that we're facing so a little bit about
the history of the GPU it's a graphics
processing unit it was originally
developed for gaming uses the typical
worth workload involves a lot of
arithmetic on like a lot of pixels
imagine or a lot of objects that are in
a frame to do rendering and shading and
it's specialized for matrix operations
because if you can imagine a
representation of a scene in a game
could be a matrix a 2d matrix of pixels
or even a 3d matrix and then you're
performing some transformations on them
operations like that so that's kind of
the background of why did people start
manufacturing these devices in the first
place and so to start to understand even
more the differences and how we might
get some benefit from computation on the
GPU we can look at the specs and these
are two kind of top-tier consumer grade
GPU versus CPU so on one side we have
nvidia z-- 2080 TI which came out pretty
recently and then on the other side this
is uh Intel's eye nine nine nine hundred
K so this is what they are we can look
at the specs and so on the one hand you
can see the GPU has a ton more cores and
even even more like processors so that's
over 4000 CUDA cores across 68 streaming
multi processors versus the Intel CPU
has eight it can get up to sixteen hyper
threads but that still is very small in
comparison to the GPU but on the other
hand you look at the base clock and the
boost clock and you can see that the CPU
in terms of the clock speed is achieving
up to three times better performance
than the GPU so if we look at this
diagram of the architecture we can start
to understand kind of why these things
are the way they are and how the GPU can
start to help us with certain workloads
so basically you have the CPU
architecture you can see a large amount
of it is related to control and caching
so these are two important pieces of how
a CPU operates you want it to interpret
your if statements your while loops and
also to be able to cache memory close to
it so it doesn't have to go into Ram and
you can see relatively fewer of the
transistors are allocated to arithmetic
units
which is the green in the GPU diagram
you can see relatively little of the
transistors are dedicated to control and
caching and so more and more can be
dedicated to arithmetic operations which
is why for simple arithmetic operations
that don't involve a lot of control flow
the GPU can end up running a lot faster
and so kind of all those factors have
led to the rise of what you'd call gpgpu
which is the idea that we can do
general-purpose computing on a GPU and
not just use it for specialized purposes
like video games graphics and so this
quote is from a paper published by
Nvidia in 2014 and basically was saying
that that in the past we thought these
devices are only good for for gaming for
graphics but now we can start to think
of them as parallel processors which is
what they really are and a bunch of the
GPU companies started making their own
kind of models of how to program these
things so CUDA which is what I'm going
to talk about today was developed by
Nvidia but also AMD had app and OpenCL
is kind of a growing open standard and
so these are different ways people are
coming up with how we can turn this
device that we have that has certain
desirable properties into something that
we can run general-purpose workloads on
and so this kind of gets into well why
am i interested in this how did I come
to be giving this talk up here and so
I'll start by talking a little bit about
my work so I work as an engineer on the
data team at compass compass is a real
estate technology platform basically
bringing together the real estate agent
with engineers for building technology
to empower them and when I specifically
work on is bringing in listing data from
a bunch of different geographies and
then we transform it we perform a lot of
conversions in normalization and so we
use a lot of common tools you might see
in data pipelines and data processing so
this includes SPARC Kafka air flow but I
also like to keep my ear to the ground
in terms of what's
in the industry around this tooling and
you know you start to read some
interesting things
this is rapids AI which is partnered
with Nvidia and their concept is that
the GPUs might be start start to be used
for this entire data processing workflow
and not just for say model training
which is a place where they've started
to be used so you might actually be able
to do your pre-processing even
visualization using the power of GPUs so
this is something that's in development
we might have GPU databases this is just
from this year
uber built kind of a GPU powered
database for doing analytics so even in
terms of what I work on professionally
there's a couple kind of advancements
that might be you know putting GPUs into
use for these kinds of data processing
or clothes but it also relates to my
copies which include deep learning so I
kind of got hooked in it through the
FAFSA a deep learning course I started
doing some competitions on Kaggle and
this is this kind of got me hooked into
thinking about these Hardware questions
so this is my computer at home that I
put together basically after leaving a
GPU running on AWS for one weekend you
got a pretty big bill and you're like
okay maybe I should start to think about
building one myself maybe some people
have been there before
and so this is kind of what got me
thinking about GPUs and and CUDA on kind
of a more general level not just related
to deep learning and specifically you
know I made a small pull request to PI
torch last year and that's kind of what
inspired this talk was this was moving
one function basically from there Python
into the C++ implementation but just
seeing kind of how that library was all
put together and how they were able to
kind of merge you know the Python API
with C++ and also CUDA programming I was
really fascinating to me and so I wanted
to kind of dive in and learn more so
that was part of the origin of this talk
so finally I get to the question that
everybody probably wanted to know
which is how can you start programming
on the GPU and so for an example I've
started out with numpy so this is this
would run on the CPU and those of you
familiar kind of with numpy might see
we're taking a random basically vector
of 10,000,000 numbers retaining two of
them and just adding them together right
and so this is something that you could
run and numpy is pretty good at this
like what I benchmarked it wasn't too
large so let's see what would the code
look like the equivalent of this on the
GPU and well that's not much change
right I'll go back to the other side and
and there's the other side and you're
like whoa so this is from library called
Q PI basically and it tries to mirror
the numpy api and it lets you start to
take advantage of GPU processing in a
pretty straightforward way like I said
just one more time here's here's numpy
q5 but when you benchmark it you can see
that actually just that switch gives you
a thirty times speed up and that's
accounting for things like you know the
GPU executes asynchronously but you want
to make sure you synchronize it so
you're you're seeing about a thirty
times speed up again just from this
change and so that's that's part of why
I think this is so cool because I think
you know how many people out there use
dumb PI for some things right you know
it's a pretty common tool in Python and
so you know if there's this drop-in
replacement that would let you get these
kinds of speed ups like that might
really help your workflow and so that
brings me into talking about kind of the
the outline of this talk and I'm going
to talk about different approaches to
doing CUDA programming from your Python
application one which I just showed you
is as a drop-in replacement to is
basically taking CUDA strings and
compiling them in an in a Python program
and then the third one which is kind of
the most complex is actually building it
as a C C++ extension to Python which
with Python allows you to do and you
know as with a lot of things I think in
programming software development these
are kind of being
levels of complexity but what comes
along with that complexity and kind of
initial setup is it gives you additional
flexibility it might unlock features of
the CUDA platform that aren't
necessarily available in say a drop-in
replacement but that you might be able
to access by kind of rolling your own so
to talk about drop-in replacement the
library I showed was lace IQ Pi which is
built as a drop-in replacement it was
originally developed for a deep learning
framework called chainer
it supports a lot of number features
some of which are pretty you know
complex like the whole indexing system
I'm pretty sure they have it working
just like numpy and then pi does a lot
of crazy things with that supports a
bunch of different data types
broadcasting there are a couple gotchas
so those are you raise your hands who
might want to think about dropping this
into your program these are things to
watch out for so it can't use data types
there are strings or objects this makes
sense if you think about the kind of
diagram I showed you that there's a ton
of arithmetic units on the GPU so they
can be working on numbers but maybe not
so good for these other kinds of data
the other thing is array creation so
enough how you can do num Qaida array
over a list it'll turn it into four you
can't do that and then the last one
which really might trip you up is if you
sum a numpy array it's gonna return a
scalar it's just one value but in qpi
returns is your dimensional array which
is gonna be a little bit different if so
that is to say that these libraries are
good and I would definitely encourage
you to try them out but definitely keep
in mind that there are certain things
that might trip you up it's not quite
going to be a total drop-in replacement
so the second way to do it like I said
is that you can compile CUDA strings in
your Python application and so before we
talk about that then we have to talk
about the CUDA API because compared to
the drop-in you're gonna actually have
to write
to code and so this is a diagram of the
basic kind of building blocks of how
CUDA programming is done so on the top
you've got a grid
you've got blocks inside that and then
you've got threads inside your blocks so
to break it down a little bit
threads are the things that actually
execute CUDA kernels and they have a
thread index and what that's used for
is basically to specify which part of
the data that thread is meant to work on
and so this is from the body of a
particular CUDA function but you can see
here if you're executing over a
2-dimensional matrix you can basically
have a thread index in the x and y axes
and that lets you specify like this
thread is meant to take this element of
the matrix and add it together and you
can imagine that this kind of simplifies
the logic if you've got a thousand
threads and I guess if you've ever tried
to write some like parallel code like
there's kind of a lot of housekeeping
that goes around like keeping track of
these thread indexes and which thread
touches which part of the matrix and a
lot of that is built into this CUDA
paradigm for you
so then blocks blocks is the next level
a block is a group of threads and the
important thing is the blocks are
required to be able to execute
independently but threads within a block
can share data there's kind of block
level shared memory and so if you do
need to do some synchronization between
your threads that is possible on the
block level and just like the threads
the block also has dimensions and
indexing so you can do is block index as
well as the size of the block and this
is if you need to do kind of more
complex computations of like what
specific bit of this matrix is is this
thread supposed to operate on grids is
something too fancy is a group of blocks
so going back to the diagram then we
kind of have these different levels and
layers of being able to achieve
parallelism so from the lowest the top
we've got threads which are executing
the CUDA
code organized into these blocks which
again can also be arranged in this
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
space so you see like the zero zero
there is the index so that block is
indexed at 0 0 and then 1 0 so the grid
itself is also a 2 dimensional group of
blocks so that's kind of threads blocks
and grids so the other kind of piece of
it when you get around to actually
executing CUDA code is kernels and
that's basically C or C++ code that
they've added a bit of extra syntax too
so specifically there's this global kind
of identifier that use you're use to
specify your kernel function and then
there's this angle bracket syntax that
lets you specify the grid size and the
block size so if you go back to here
obviously this is a parameter that you
have control over so you can say how
many blocks go in my grid and then how
many threads go in my block and that's
kind of one way to tune the performance
and so by using this syntax you can kind
of play around with that and see well
what's gonna be the most effective so
this is one example of what a kernel
might look like so this global
identifier at the top here is saying
this is the kernel so this is what's
gonna execute on the GPU whereas this
main function is what executes on the
CPU and that's kind of the relationship
in a CUDA program is you have your host
which is the CPU of your device which is
the term for the GPU and basically your
program starts executing on a CPU and
then as soon as it gets to one of these
kernels that's going to be executed on
device it basically calls that and
communicates and does data transfer
across from the CPU to the GPU to be
able to run this and you can see here
that at the top the kernel is making use
of these kind of terms I was talking
about so block index block dimension
thread index to figure out in this case
it's adding to two dimensional matrices
like figure out which piece of it the
thread is actually meant to
to work so that's kind of the high-level
overview of the coot API so we get to PI
CUDA basically this was built by a
researcher it's used for a lot of
scientific and research projects there's
even a research paper about this library
which is how necessarily something you
see for all the code you find on github
I was a little bit surprised so what
does it do basically this is an example
code that kind of gets to the main thing
that it gives to you as a programmer
which is you can take the CUDA kernel
code so if we if we go back here this is
what a kernel looks like and this global
function is what's going to execute on
the device so what's going to execute on
the GPU
you can basically pull that out and
within your Python program supply that
as a string to this source module object
and then there's an additional this.get
function call and this basically
compiles it as a GPU kernel and then
pulls it into your Python program to
allow you to be able to call it over
your objects so this is one way that
lets you start to write CUDA code but
you don't have to step out of like a
Python environment because all that
objects and and whatnot are still gonna
be just like like in a Python program
and so this is one of the nice things is
in PI CUDA you get automatic memory
management so basically once something
goes out of scope or once that you
delete something it's actually gonna
free the allocated memory on the GPU and
I wanna guess in describing like C
extensions and kind of the most manual
way to do it you'll see that that can
actually save you a lot of hassle these
are other kind of classes and provides
so it's an in out and in out classes to
describe your arrays or matrices and
these handle memory transfer between the
CPU and GPU basically there's a lot of
steps you have to do in order to perform
let's say you have a numpy array on your
CPU you want to like double all the
elements these are all the steps you
have to do to be able to accomplish
and there's a lot of them in terms of
creating memory moving data across and
so pi cuda also has certain higher level
abstractions we're basically in means
this array is meant to go to the GPU and
it handles that for you and and out is
even a little bit more complicated we're
just saying this numpy array say is
meant to go into the GPU be processed in
your CUDA kernel and then come back out
and as long as you're okay with that
happening automatically pi cuda can
handle that behind the scenes and the
last thing which i think is really
useful is automatic error checking
so because cuda is some of the
operations executed asynchronously and
so collecting and servicing the errors
can be really challenging and including
this this is from the documentation if
an asynchronous error occurs it will be
reported by some subsequent unrelated
runtime function call and that's not a
pretty confusing to me it's like okay
well if it ever happens in one thing
basically the next function you call is
gonna error and so pi cuda also handles
out for you and raises them as kind of
specific Python exceptions in the
paradigm you might be more familiar with
and finally another interesting bit is
you can do meta programming
so basically when I was talking about
threads blocks grids basically you have
to tune those parameters like how many
threads in a block how many blocks in a
grid just I mean just like you might do
with parallel programming on a CPU and
it's often done with heuristics but PI
CUDA basically says forget heuristics we
can do this by running things and we can
Imperial empirically determine how to
actually set these parameters so this is
one example which is actually using
ginger templating so like I said because
the module is a string in Python
it kind of like follows that anyway you
can create a Python string you can pass
and compile it so this is kind of a
clever kind of crazy way of doing it but
you can basically pass in different
parameters in terms of types so you can
see it's parameterizing over the float
type it's you can pass in a different
block size a different thread block size
and it basically
sofirst templates your string
then kind of just in time compiles it
into a CUDA kernel so I mean that's
really cool because you know especially
as you're trying to play around with
this and like you know this week I was
trying to compile different things and
see how they ran but this step would be
would be a lot faster just to be able to
basically you loop through different
configurations in Python and be able to
see the results empirically okay so then
the last minute which like I said is the
most manual but it might give you the
most flexibility is CUDA as a see
extension and so first let's talk about
Python C extensions so python but
because the you know the interpreter is
C based you can extend it with C and C++
programs you can add new modules of your
own design and that's used in even a lot
of programs that want to achieve a
better performance on the CPU so for
example numpy numpy links into certain
CPU system or c system calls rather to
be able to achieve the kind of
performance it does so this is already a
paradigm being used in kind of high
performance computing settings and so
the question is okay so I know I can get
my C or C++ program into Python as an
extension so how do I get my CUDA
program to a C or C++ and basically CUDA
well there's different forms of it but
what I've been talking about is to refer
to as CUDA C and so this is basically C
but with a special syntax and so Nvidia
provides you with this nvcc compiler
which basically takes your CUDA secret
source code and does a couple of things
one it turns the kernel into like
assembly or binary for operations on the
GPU it takes one of these special
syntaxes and replaces it with runtime
calls and then finally you can also have
it just compile the host like CPU code
and so nvcc can do all of it like itself
so there's just one compilation step
that basically generates output in CUDA
as well as the code you would need to
run on the CPU to launch the kernel and
so on the Python side you can get very
complex this is a very good github repo
it cheats a little bit and uses sites on
but there's a couple options you can use
when you're kind of going between C++
and Python
so cyclone is one of them swig is
another one that's also there's an
example in this repo so basically once
you find some way of creating your
extension then you need to use setup
tools to compile it and link it together
and this code is also from that
repository basically in set of tools in
your basically set up PI you create an
extension you can specify the sources as
well as how to compile it and so you can
see here that we're using the CUDA
libraries and you can see nvcc as well
as GCC to basically compile all this
together and package it up and then that
will basically link in to our Python
program but I would encourage you this
part gets very complex if you're
interested in this I would encourage you
to check out that code because those
people put together some very complex
tricks to actually be able to get all
this to come together so why would you
want to do that I just said like it's
really complex one is manual memory
management which you might see as a
downside you're like we're using Python
why do I want to manage my
memory and this is kind of the
constructor of that GPU adder class
you see Matlock's they're like whoa but
and here's this here's a destructor so
you have to call free and having forbid
you don't but basically why would you
want this but I think there is a benefit
because there's certain manual memory
management features in CUDA so some
advanced things mapped memory I think is
the most interesting which is basically
like you can map memory between your
host which is CPU again and device and
basically be able to access it without
having to do an explicit data transfer
and so that can be pretty cool but
basically there's a couple features that
might only be accessible once you get
down to the level of doing this kind of
stuff the other thing is and I know this
might be heresy because it's a Python
conference but you do get a compiler and
I would say the nice thing about that is
like you're writing in a language that's
unfamiliar to you right I you know at
least for me like I don't do a ton of
CUDA programming even when I use it I'm
mostly using Python and so being able to
have the compiler tell you this went
wrong on these lines I would say when I
was working on tweaking this C extension
stuff I actually felt kind of grateful
for the compiler so that can be kind of
nice so to conclude one I want to talk a
little bit about accessing a GPU so you
might be interested in playing around
with some of this stuff yourself one
google collab is like really awesome
it's a browser-based notebook interface
and it's free and it gives you access to
a GPU and so some of the more custom
stuff I don't think you'll be able to
like link extensions on it but you can
definitely download q pi and play around
with that and you know a PI CUDA you
should also be able to install and so
that's free and then even like cloud GPU
instances are starting to become
accessible so on AWS you can get it for
less than a dollar an hour if you just
want to spend you know two or three or
four hours playing around with
or Google cloud their pricing a little
bit different this is per GPU I think
you also need an instance to attach it
to but it still should be under a dollar
an hour if this stuff kind of interests
you and you you want to play around with
it so then the last question i'm talking
about is is where do you go next so you
kind of have gone through this talk i've
submitted you to this talk and what can
you do with it so one I would say you
could start to think about how you can
apply CUDA and GPU programming to your
workflow like I said that's like a
really active area of development a lot
of things coming out and so especially
if you have your work has anything to do
with data pipelines processing or
obviously machine learning and deep
learning but that's already kind of
already been done so that's something to
start think about the other thing is you
know now you have access to like 4000
cores what do you do with it so you
start learning a little bit more about
parallel programming algorithms how to
make use of that like most effectively
because you can do cooler things with it
than just like adding 10 million numbers
to each other and then the other thing
is if this stuff kind of excites you
there's also a bunch of other kinds of
devices to start thinking about so
people talk about that XP you concept so
Google has TP use which are civilly for
deep learning people are starting to
come up with all sorts of devices and
then you can kind of go a different
direction to and start doing FPGA which
basically is building hardware to
execute like certain algorithms so you
know there's a whole device side of it
too and kind of getting beyond the CPU
paradigm and figuring out well can I
come up with a specialized device that's
better than this kind of one single
general smart thing so that's that's
what I was suggestive if you found this
to be interesting thank you so much
there's my Twitter I'll probably post
other they post the slides and related
code
on there so if you have any more
questions thank you so much
[Applause]